I guess I'm back in today I want to talk
about a discussion I had with a woman
who had repeated heart attacks and she
kept going the doctor and the arteries
were clear she had no obstruction and
she didn't know what to do so she wanted
some advice so I want to talk about what
I told her okay first of all you have to
realize that you can have a heart attack
without having the obstruction to one of
your arteries and that is called
myocardial infarction with
non-obstructive coronary arteries okay
nothing you need to know that but
there's two things that can happen
number one is the actual heart muscle
itself goes into a cramp or the artery
goes into a spasm obstructing the blood
flow to the heart muscle itself causing
the heart attack now what I told her to
do was do some research in the area of
vitamin E deficiencies why because when
you have a deficiency of vitamin E the
need for oxygen in the muscle tissue
especially in the heart goes up
significantly okay
so you don't have oxygen there it starts
to cramp you also can get necrosis which
is breakdown of the heart muscle fibers
with a vitamin E deficiency you have
neuromuscular degeneration so the
connection between the nerve and the
heart muscle can degenerate that can
create a big problem and another symptom
you can have a vitamin E is you can have
a myopathy which is a disease of the
heart muscle itself in certain studies
vitamin D deficiencies in the blood were
significantly higher in angina cases and
vitamin E is an antioxidant and it's
even carried by LDL which is so called
bad cholesterol that's carried to the
blood vessel to actually provide healing
for any lesions or oxidation that's
happening in the artery because vitamin
E is a very powerful antioxidant it has
functions for nerve conduction and
neuromuscular control now how does
someone become deficient in vitamin E
well the biggest way is just to consume
a lot of refined carbohydrates in the
form of breads pasta cereal crackers
it's things like that okay normally the
grain is loaded with vitamin E it's in
the wheat germ but when you grind the
grain and you expose it to air
and you basically oxidize all the
vitamin E so when you consume those
products you create deficiencies in your
body so I don't recommend you get your
vitamin E from grains even whole grains
I recommend you get them from the leafy
greens and sunflower seeds things like
that or go to the health a store and get
a vitamin E complex
don't use a synthetic version okay you
get the complex because vitamin E comes
in many different parts and the exact
fraction of the vitamin E complex that
helps angina is vitamin E to that
fraction and I don't even recommend just
taking that get the whole complex and
take that especially if you have
symptoms of angina or anything related
to heart be very very important one
additional note I want to bring up when
a woman goes through menopause she loses
the function of the ovaries okay now the
pituitary doesn't have to work as much
because it's not sending signals down to
the ovaries anymore so what could happen
the need for vitamin E goes down so the
pituitary is not storing vitamin E as
much and this could be one of the
reasons why women are at greater risk
for heart attack after menopause than
before menopause and what's also
interesting is when you take vitamin E
in its complex form you can actually
improve hot flashes okay what a
coincidence so anyway there you have it
do some research and vitamin E if you
have any of these symptoms at all all
right thanks for watching so if you want
more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that